manifestantes saltando en la piscina de
la residencia presidencial en colombo
son las increíbles imágenes de sri lanka
este sábado muestra del consenso y la
cólera de la población la policía no
pudo contener a las miles de personas
que se reunieron alrededor de la
residencia oficial del presidente y
cientos de ellos irrumpieron en el
edificio llegando hasta la habitación
del mandatario
de la nave la gente ha venido aquí para
liberar esta presión cuando ve si los
grupos de esta casa es evidente que no
tienen tiempo para trabajar para el país
warner lugares así son un desperdicio de
los recursos nacionales tácticas anpact
áspero radar después de haber tenido que
huir del palacio presidencial el viernes
por razones de seguridad el presidente
rajapaksa aceptó este sábado dimitir a
el próximo miércoles algo que los
manifestantes piden desde hace meses el
primer ministro también aceptó renunciar
con la condición de que todos los
partidos aceptaran formar un gobierno de
coalición pero no fue suficiente para
calmar descontento de la multitud que
prendió fuego a su casa privada por la
noche el actual gobierno ha sido
señalado por su mala gestión en la peor
crisis económica desde la independencia
del país la inflación ha subido hasta el
70 por ciento provocando escases de
alimentos medicinas y combustible
crisis que ha empujado a muchos a
protestar desafiando los toques de queda
y las prohibiciones de manifestarse